c'est bien connu sur internet on trouve
tout on peut tout acheter
y compris un centre éducatif fermé la
petite annonce ne mentionne pourtant
qu'un bâtiment usage d'hébergement vente
notamment une cour goudronnée un parc
arboré et intérêts entièrement clos mais
dans l'autunois tout le monde connaît le
lieu et personne ne semble surpris que
la mairie décidé de le vendre sur
internet
donc j'avais des années qu'ils ont parlé
de fermer alors là puis je peux c'est un
avantage pour les pour les gens qui
habitent le coin mais ça qu'il faut
regarder
pourquoi pas c'est ça ça celui qui
mettra le plus cher quoi la poêle je
trouve que c'est bien l'association qui
gère le centre éducatif fermé doit
libérer ses locaux au plus tard au 1er
juillet la mairie d'autun estimant que
cette alternative à l'incarcération des
mineurs ne marche pas alors mettre en
vente les lieux alors qu'ils sont encore
occupés est ce une provocation à la
ville d'autun on est assez numérique et
on met souvent en vente nos bâtiments
sur le bon coin parce qu'aujourd'hui le
bon coin ça c'est un site de petites
annonces à la fois immobilière d'emplois
donc on a d'autres bâtiments en vente
sur le bon coin qui ont fait moins de
bruit
deux cent mille euros c'est la somme
demandée par la mairie mais ici ce n'est
pas vraiment le prix qui inquiète ses
dépens un qui va le vendre
et le premier magistrat d'autun a déjà
une idée bien précise
ce bâtiment peut tout à fait servir à de
l'hébergement notamment en ce qu'on
appelle backpack c'est-à-dire de
randonneurs de familles qui sont dans le
morvan pour la nature de vététistes on a
des pistes de vtt à proximité on a de
grandes balades
on a un certain nombre d'activités et
puis on a besoin à autun d'hébergement
touristique qui nous en manque quelques
investisseurs ont déjà pris contact
affaire à suivre